it's a big night for us so first night
together as a show and it's the first
time I can remember seeing LeBron it's
your first night rookie yeah that's why
we got doughnuts we got big news though
we got LeBron on the headset quarter I'm
tossing it over to wade a drag man
what's going on Trey so you know we
talked before the game I said I need you
to have a big one too so you can come on
and I'll let me out the game I know
who's gonna be 36 you put a lot of
pressure on me man before the game a lot
of pressure man I see I got a couple
questions for you bro you know as
someone and we in the studio talking
about this but as someone who went to a
finals a finals in a row what are you
looking for out of AD you know being the
next guy next to you
someone who hasn't been in this position
and this later half of the season what
would you be looking for from him and
the rest of your teammates
I mean we're gonna play a lot of you
know regular-season games it's gonna
feel like playoff intensity you know
because I everybody get up to play us so
a lot of our games especially on the
road is gonna have some type of playoff
intensity so 80 being and you know not
as experienced in the playoffs you kind
of used that you know as some experience
you know to kind of tell him like you
know tonight is gonna be one of those
games kind of envision that being in the
postseason as well so you know ATS been
consistent all year man you know scoring
the ball rebounding the ball being a
defensive player of the year that he's
capable of being and he's been doing
that all year so you know it's all about
consistency and also his leadership
you know his leadership has gotten
better and better and better as the
months that went on and you know for me
I'm just kind of watching from afar give
my one to Saint when when needed but you
know just knowing that home you know
just let him do his thing yeah 100%
and also to me yo we all talked about
this obviously 35 years old 17 years in
the NBA but I feel like I've been as
your teammate I saw you in your prime
and I saw how great you were but now at
this age with all experience you have
you seem like on some nights the game is
just easy and you've gotten better talk
to all the kids out there is a four-time
MVP as a three-time champion how you
continue to get better and the things
they should be looking to do as a
basketball player to inspire
to always be their best selves I think
it's um you know when you have all the
athleticism you have all the quickness
you have all the speed you're able to
jump as high as you can at that point in
time in your career I think that's when
you need to sharpen your mind even more
so when you get later on in your career
you know your mind is sharp you know
we're all NBA players and for a reason
you know because our god-given ability
the way we're able to do things with the
basketball the way we're able to come
together as a team but it's you know the
ones that you know kind of stay in the
top tier as once we can also I don't
think the game is well so you know for
me being able to you know give it to the
young guys as well want taking care of
your body you know taking care of your
body also being able to be coachable and
then just putting in the work putting in
the work either you know when you feel
them great go on the floor put your time
in on the floor get better and better
better and then when you're not for them
is greater your ladies feeling you know
heavy or your body feeling you know
heavy then you know getting your
stretching getting your Isis you know
getting your massages get all that stuff
you know to kind of just prolong your
career and prolong your game and also
just having that mental that mental
Fitness you know always help you long
long run down your career LeBron I play
with some of the all-time greats
including yourself well you're the first
guy that you wrote goals on the board so
what were the goals for the Lakers when
you first got there well not last year
but this year you know with the addition
of ad in our and all those guys what
were the goals for this team I think it
was all about mental focus you know
obviously our long-term our long-term
goal is to be able to post up you know
that trophy but that's you know further
on down the road you know and for us
being a new group having many new
acquisitions that we had an off season
bringing a new team is how fast we can
jail how fast we can come together as a
brotherhood how fast we can have this
camaraderie and have the same goal in
mind that everyday we're trying to work
championship habits you know and we have
you know quite a few guys that's been
able to you know win championships in
this league so you know having those
habits every single day also you know
just given all the game to a tee
understanding how important he is to
this whole thing you know him being 26
years old him being you know the great
player that he is and you know and
everybody just kind of following you
know me and ad or you know how we how we
practice how we you know how we are on
the plane how we are on the locker room
and things of that nature so we just
want to continue to get better as the
season go on and you know with the
all-star break coming up you know right
after
all sort break that's when it really
gets going so I was just having that
mental focus this year it seems like the
Lakers have really committed on the
defensive end which has allowed you guys
obviously to have you guys our top four
and lead defensively you guys are able
to get out in transition and give fans I
mean just to have to guard you and AD
and transition first can you talk about
that commitment and where you feel like
you're at defensively and then secondly
listen D Wade's a rookie so we had to
make him bring in doughnuts today I was
just wondering if there's anything else
that you know maybe making the rookies
do backpack okay so to answer your first
question Canada's you know for us now
Frank Vogel being a defensive minded
coach D Wade and and I both know those
wars we had with the Indiana patients
and how great they were defensively and
then you bring in Avery Bradley you
bring in a Danny Green you bring in
Anthony Davis you bring in a Dwight
Howard you know you have these defensive
minded guys that buy into it right away
and then everybody else falls into place
you know so it's been great for us you
know all year we have so many great
defenders both at the wing spot both at
the point of position and then an
interior with javale ad and Dwight so
that's worked out for us tremendously
for the second question you always can
now you could have him wear like a
little Dora the explora book bag or
Sponge Bob Squarepants book bag or you
can make him carry yo bag into work you
know he could carry all y'all bags into
work bring y'all some newspapers all you
know you know rookie duty stuff like
that and stuff like that
my bad dee way my fault my fault you
right LeBron man six threes tying the
season high and not one not two but five
of them in the fourth
take me through how you were feeling
towards the end of this game n you know
they cut the lead in the third quarter
and I knew I was going back in the
fourth so just tried to put a little
pressure see if my hand was hot you know
my teammates did a good job getting me
the ball and you know they were you know
kind of daring me to shoot the ball and
something I work on every single day so
I just believed in my ability shooter
from the perimeter if you haven't went
in the crowd went crazy my teammates you
know beat me up I ain't got jumped like
that since you know I was like grown up
in the places that you shouldn't grow up
in but you know it's fun man it's fun
just to be able to you know have a
moment like that where you get in a zone
and your teammates are celebrating and
cheering for you and your crowd is going
crazy so all the blessings to the man
above that's for sure yeah it wasn't
just crowd going crazy social media was
going nuts another one
DJ count James knocking down shots
Cameron Peter saying we're not worthy
we're not worthy and then Julie and Adam
LeBron and practically the dude at the
arcade man it was awesome to watch Papa
Schadt appreciate I appreciate it guys
that's for sure
all right so we did notice something on
the amazing app that is tick tock is
that LeBrons Ben dance with the kids
doings Ben dance with the kids
I need Shaq to cut away it who did it
better here's LeBron how much these
shoes is on I got a big dogs breathe
[Music]
you got the wrong with the all right the
winner well I play with both these guys
I'm good friends are both like I believe
this if America one two three four I
appreciate y'all man I'll see y'all what
I tell my boy Joe fell McGee I sent up
now for show we show we show awesome
right strength what are the season man
is there be well
LeBron man wait you can really get some
pull around here well he made me look
good you know since I've given away all
the Hazen do I gotta bring doughnuts
again it was that it was that enough
right there push your goes up to kill
you man bro we're not don't know I like
the door explore doughnuts